[Musique]
dernier jour de visite ce jeudi pour
sébastien lecornu qui s'est penché sur
l'agriculture à la réunion c'est à saint
benoît sur l'exploitation de la
plantation mélissa que le ministre les
outre mer s'est rendu je suis
plantations mélissa je m'occupe de la
partie production agricole donc la
production agricole qui essentiellement
tournés sur fleurs fruits et feuillages
tropicaux et après il ya toute la
panoplie de fruits tropicaux qu'on peut
cultiver l'héritage de l'exploitation de
des années des années 60 de mon grand
père je parle des letchis bras cannot
donc l'origine du letchi bra kanon c'est
ici on fait après plein d'autres choses
que ce soit de la carambole de la banane
de la petite banane à la bad à bananes
blanche après la visite de
l'exploitation sébastien lecornu a
participé à une table ronde avec les
acteurs du monde agricole
ce matin je confirme évidemment
l'objectif collectif que nous nous
sommes assignés collectivités
territoriales évidemment état chambres
consulaires et les différentes filières
qui est d'avoir 7 sept saulx suffisance
alimentaire pour 2030 alors ça veut dire
qu'on aura besoin quand même de tout le
monde
déjà alors besoin des réunionnaises et
des réunionnais est ce que qui dit
marché local il comportement local
il s'est passé des choses pendant que
lead et le confinement dans lequel on a
réappris à consommer parfois très local
a pris aller sur la vente directement
parlé avec le président de la chambre
il ya quelques instants ça c'est une
dimension culturelle s'est passé quelque
chose pendant leur confinement mais il
faut le garder faut arriver à le
conserver
il ya aussi la la la diversification et
ça je pense que si on a choisi cette
cette exploitation au delà de la très
grande gentillesse du couple qui nous a
accueillis c'est de se dire qu'à un
moment donné on a besoin pour assurer un
niveau de revenus suffisants
nos agriculteurs d'avoir des sources
diversifiées et là vous avez un peu de
tout un mot quand même pour le président
du conseil départemental
est ce que le conseil départemental de
la réunion s'engage de manière assez
assez unique sur sur les questions
agricoles je le dis parce que j'étais
présente département moi même vous le
savez j'ai je préside favorisé mon
département j'étais ministre en charge
des collectivités territoriales donc
j'ai quand même beaucoup voyagé et peu
de conseils départementaux en métropole
dans l'hexagone ou en outre-mer
s'investissent autant sur ces questions
soient ces questions avec toi de c'est à
saluer parce que ses remarques quand je
vois d'abord bien sûr les problèmes
c'est de toujours lutté pour aller le
plus loin possible en termes de qualité
et de quantité produite ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire une agriculture
capable d'accompagner les consommateurs
réunionnais qui ont besoin de produits
frais des deux circuits courts et là
bien sûr le monde agricole s'adapte et
l'état comme le département nous
accompagnons ces efforts par la mise en
place de crédits venant bien sûr du
budget du département mais aussi de
l'union européenne par la mise en place
de nouveaux de nouvelles filières de
nouvelles filières structurées par la
mise en place de nouveaux outils de
transformation
et bien voilà un monde dynamique un
monde en mutation
la matinée s'est achevée par un déjeuner
avec les acteurs du tourisme à
sainte-rose à la ferme auberge la
cayenne
[Musique]